mean what surprised me more besides
these three dogs like apil David wood no
no no it's it's one dog three heads okay
one dog Aus another dog David Woods the
other dog Tommy Robinson there's three
dogs or one dog so it's one one but
there's three one one no it's one I want
like hij won the debate he won he won
the
debate man
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
brothers and sisters and dear friends we
had the pleasure the honor of being live
a vvvv VIP VIP watching how Muhammad
hijab prepared for this debate mentally
psychologically notes his defense was
impregnable he's Alexander and
anyways but it was phenomenal I think I
really enjoyed it um William Lane Craig
is a really big name like he was the big
name of Christianity that was left and
now that that that dragon has been
slayed yeah I mean I think it's time to
move on now I mean what surprised me
more besides these free dogs like apus
David wood no no no it's it's one dog
three heads okay one dog apus another
dog David Woods the other dog Tommy
Robinson there's three dogs or one dog
so it's one one one but there's three
one one no it's one I want like hij won
the debate he won the he won the debate
do you mean won one or one William Lane
Craig
David okay good all right perfect so let
me get this right Craig
Craig William Lane Craig actually he
actually agreed with the Quran which it
was profound and hij pointed out which
was actually phenomenal the fact that
Allah says you know in the
Quan he does not beget nor is he
begotten so the the Christians like a
denomination believe that they believe
that Jesus was eternally begotten no the
Protestants the Catholics oh the
Catholics and the Orthodox all except
something called Eternal generation
which is that the son is eternally being
generated from the Father which they
term as begotten okay I don't know if
this more confusing but they're both
co-equal and they separate beings
however the question that hijab posited
was the father yeah who created the
universe was it the father was it the
son was it the Holy Spirit none of them
talk about the Holy Spirit them talk
about so so so uh will and Craig
believes that no he actually doesn't
believe in that so he doesn't believe in
that he believes that so that's and
that's heretical oh he's a he's well
he's worse than that okay so he believes
that if the son is begotten he cannot be
God yeah yeah okay so that's why didn't
accept this is this is this ISAT after
us please okay so this very interesting
because if there are free beings so if
apus decides which he has that incest is
okay with your own daughter and way oh
yeah you know yes agree with that so if
dog second David wood and dog third
Tommy Robinson say you are not going to
do that which will whose will is ridden
like whose will overtakes
AP wants to do that which he does he
said he does there's no problem with
that but the other two say no you can't
do that because that is not moral
because they they're
Christians who's will because look CU a
don't don't ask these questions you're
just supposed to take it on belief
that's that's the yeah okay cuz he's got
his tongue out he's very eager to do it
a man oh that's not nice okay so that
was one of the highlights of the debate
aldah which he did not really address um
what else did you catch on I think the
Eternal generation argument is so
confusing like they believe that the son
uh is independent he's a separate being
he coequal coeternal however he's
eternally being generated from the
father stop stop stop stop stop I can't
deal with it anymore W that was that was
painful and and the the the audacity to
bring to you know what I found very
interesting this dilemma is so
problematic so problematic that they are
actually looking and hunting for Trinity
in the Quran like I'm not talking about
their belief they're thinking we have a
trinity they're trying to get Allah's
attributes and divide it into parts and
say oh you guys have the same problem no
we don't we do not have the same problem
and the example you gave of free dogs
it's catastrophic as an argument in
itself but I believe it was brilliant
alhamdulillah like the way hij prepared
for it and I'll be honest with you I was
looking at the comments a lot of people
were expecting far more from William Lan
Craig they were expect there was a big
disappointment you know what was more
disappointing was that we no we expected
well that obviously but we expected
class from him yes like right from the
get-go William Lane Craig started by
attacking Islam and is it any wonder
that the reaction to hijabs video is
going to be done by a handful of who
Heretics Christians islamophobes people
that chew the Quran spit it out it's
like they need an army to pick up and
clean off the or clean up the mess of
William Blane Craig so the defeat was so
catastrophic that immediately after on
their Channel and islamophobe and
atheist and free Heretics who are
against William Lane Craig are reviewing
it I mean it says it all man I think the
are you going to janaza with me or
tomorrow uh I think yeah let's go
because you're supposed to bury the
deceased as quick as possible that's
only for the Muslim let this one smell
let the people smell okay nice guys
watch the full debate inshah on mad's
channel inshah like comment and share on
his channel in brothers and sisters it
was absolutely phenomenal brilliant
discussion uh again William L Craig
William Craig Craig David William Craig
seven days William L Craig again M day
he got smashed on Tuesday he's needs to
come to Islam on Wednesday Wednesday and
first day go Juma on Friday come
on Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorize an all of this
and so much more can be on your scale of
Good Deeds click the link and donate
what you can and share the video for
even extra reward